overwatch is competitive mode has
finally arrived on the public test realm
and with it it brings an entirely new
system of ranked play to the game the
way the matches work in this mode is
each team takes turns attacking and the
score is based upon how many points they
actually capture after each team has a
chance to attack the scores are tallied
and the team with the most wins how it
differs from quick play is that if the
score is tied they go into sudden death
in that the attacking team is decided by
a coin flip and will have two minutes to
capture a single point after you play
the ten placement matches the game will
assign you a skill rating and will use
that number to find a group with a
similar average it's this method of
matchmaking that makes a mode feel
competitive you will end up playing with
people who are actually on the same
level as you skill wise instead of
whatever number is below the portrait
the mode self feels frantic exhilarating
knowing that the matches mean something
but it also does a lot to put the focus
of the game on the actual objectives
during payload for example the
individual checkpoints are a lot more
valuable this time around now that
capturing and defending those points
determines an actual score players will
want to keep a closer watch and protect
them at all costs and by putting
people's ranks at stake as they can rise
and fall from match to match the mode
seems to encourage people to care about
the game and not go running off to try
to keep their kill streak going it's all
about teamwork here and even playing on
the public test realm I could sense
people were trying really hard to work
together and to help the team succeed
the group matchmaking seems like it will
work particularly well and will give the
players the balance and even matches
they've been waiting for since the game
was released and with new rewards during
each three-month long season of
competitive mode including exclusive
icons sprays and holy crab gold weapons
it's bound to have people come flocking
back to the game the new mode is still
in its testing phase as Blizzard is
continuing to work out some balance
issues with the sudden death portion of
the game but it'll hopefully be released
within the next month so in the meantime
boot up overwatch hop on the PTR and
test the mode out for yourself